you know this French Montana yes I know
you don't listen you know about yeah
janessa where is the birthday again
what do you think when you see the
artisan this is not a good idea
there Islamophobic things I think yeah
I'm good
French Montana don't do this don't do
this stop this Smee laughing tada
Salam alaikum how you guys doing I
beginning a lot of requests recently I
was meaning to do it sometime earlier
but just been so preoccupied and busy
but people never questioned there was a
very provocative video made and people
been asking me to do a little reaction
comment on it and it was by this Kareem
who made a video leave a stage name is a
French Montana have you heard of him
yeah
I think he saw from Morocco but let's
get right into it this is the trailer
and let's see what what kind of a
message is trying to bring what we can
derive from this and benefits benefit
yeah
[Music]
so that's him right Kareen that's his
real name
see these are really good because yeah
in Britain let there be run another boot
sir
not smoking so we know there's not
practicing with Montana right the head
of the ship wanted uh
[Music]
one two three four five what do you get
online over than four more than four
we'll do it without the music he's
throwing on some gang signs or double
signs shake tonic science
so they said this is like album club for
a trailer or something he's talking
about making salon
he got this sign what is that now you
got his sister with the hijab now so we
went from the copy job
we go
[Music]
well we'll have why she making see the
kind of like that rock slow speed
this is trying to doing some of these
what is I think they call that like some
lumenarrows luminaries we'll also be
talking about a very another satanic
group oops I mean a famous group out
here in Bosnia they callin the boubakr
rallies but no this one guys it's his
name yeah so we can kind of incorporate
both because they're also people this
this group now is also coming from they
made an album called pact with the devil
so but this is this cream he's at he's
obviously Muslim you can see from this
clip here serious question ask me what
do you say that people that are gonna
blame the attacks on budget asking him
about people shouldn't letting other
people out right
so so the point is um all right we know
there there's one thing between beside a
empty label right Muslim nowadays you
have people who would call themselves
Muslim identify with Islam but you know
the practice is just zero what do you
think what trying to dissect when we see
why the point the question is okay on
one side is very clear you know this
these things that these rappers these
musicians call for you know call to
promiscuity adultery I mean just follows
all evil things right but now what you
have is why are you taking something
that is at the top you know of let's say
morality you know a Muslim woman wearing
account this is a woman who has
dedicated her life to the Creator
you know Christian would you tattoo like
a nun right but now why are you bringing
into the question Muslims are asking why
do you think they're bringing this into
their videos now well I think just to go
one step back why would anybody bring
any of the religious or sectarian or any
symbolism in the his music and any songs
because I think it it it goes and this
is just like following orders because
obviously when they sing and they they
say some things that they make pacts
with the devil and they do so they
obviously make some kind of deal to
become more successful to become more
attractive for people who are following
them so they obviously obey the devil in
one way or another we don't know how
don't have any connections in the devil
but obviously they do these things under
the orders because why would somebody
who's successful now out of seven if you
see those fingers like the roses and
like Lady Gaga or some who were no same
size yes normal like she's normally
dressed girl has very big talent sings
well and then all of sudden she become
dressing like some like ancient Egypt
like Queens or still showing some time
so for anybody who's thinking why who
who order her to do this like who
directed her obviously she didn't have
any Egyptian ancestry background so now
she's going back like this is symbolism
of ideology that she's falling why would
somebody now bring Islam into all of
these things one of the things probably
just to provoke the Muslims to confuse
people who are looking at this want to
show the niqab is some completely out of
context or in some context that you
could never relate to and also I'm
thinking about it like this is a way to
insult the Muslim social because
definitely if you show a Muslim lady who
in our culture and our religion is
protected far far away from these things
now you put put ladies under the car and
hijab and put them in this kind of like
worst case videos you you we have to
know that they they they are these
satanic dark forces right this is just
very clear it's on there then you have
the forces of light you know Allah the
Creator sent us you know the guidance
and tells us clearly what is defined as
good how to live our lives what our
purpose is but it just it just it's it's
very saddening to see many of our youth
you
when we asked that lady at the juice
place you know if she knew about this so
eagerly what's called boubakr le parc
many guys never heard of them but
they're here in Bosnia the ones who made
an album is an album color called Pacwa
devil and they're supposed to be again
if they were if you know one of the
songs I heard because is not false I
heard that in one of the songs of this
album he said like something like I'm
tired to work for small money so I made
a pact to the devil so like yeah he's
giving us hints about something so even
we've you are classifying this as these
are like it just keeps getting worse and
worse so the lady there at the juice
place we asked do you know this person
and and she was what did she say she
said this is like something stuck for
like buzz but what has that she's not
practicing Muslim yeah oh yeah she's not
my quadric she spotted it but do you
think this is a desensitization we're
over and over just desensitizing we just
get more desensitized and then people
start to accept these things and a lot
of people be like why you judging
brother why are you just and the other i
mean look when people are breaking the
laws let's say you have a murderer
you have someone who's like physically
murdering people or breaking the laws of
the country and then the person says hey
you know
of America or Loeb Bosnia I mean you'd
be like come on man there's certain
etiquette certain way you have to have
to conduct yourself now on the other
side you have people who are killing
people spiritually with this music
people are calling people to everything
that the majority almost all the things
that the Creator this hates and calls us
to stay away from harmful things
spiritually toxic things that are that
are spiritually murdering killing our
soul the children the adults people who
listen to the children I think the main
attackers and children are children yet
this was not only this modern technology
and fools parents cannot prevent anymore
the access to their children what
they're going to listen and boubakr
ellie and then they're becoming crazy
famous and specially and for the young
generation and when you listen to the
lyrics it's it's horrible horrible like
they're singing about about sex about
only about these things sex drugs
immorality and how and this is not
something that would be a for grown-up
immoral immoral were grown up this is
like they're singing to the young kids
to young girls that they should go out
to be promiscuous do all these things
and you choose which is really really
next level yeah we talked about you you
mentioned it's just like when you got 1g
2g 3g just like the 5 g 5g is coming out
now and now this is like the 5g of
immorality 5g of encourage it just keeps
meaning that it just keeps getting worse
and worse so we have to you know we're
talking about this because we have to be
a awake islam awakens you
and it gives you the direction in life
you know which way you need to be going
so you cannot be falling into these
Shaitaan wants to confuse you menu for
example now we cannot explain all the
things we know outwardly what they are
doing
same like it's really good connections
at 5g everybody is saying okay we're
gonna have much faster internet much
faster data transferring and everything
but then nobody even knows what are the
side effects of these high radiation
some of the scientists are saying this
is like having microwave in your still
the whole series microwave and you don't
even know what are the possibilities
same with this music they're using the
computers they have this outta tune this
modern way of music and changing voices
you're saying that now we cannot even
decipher anymore what the Shaitaan is
doing like as Muslim sisters be away
from so but we don't even know what yeah
constantly desensitizing the human being
corrupting not only the minds the hearts
using fusion mass confusion manipulation
and you know the thing is like it's one
thing if you because these people were
would identify is probably being are
Muslim they're Muslim and you were
mentioning something about the beard you
think God has big beard yeah fellas yeah
and at one time people are making fun of
Muslims here actually they call them
certain names if you had a beard
yeah but now they're now part like
idolizing these guys but the thing is
for them also you know it's if this
message gets to them I mean what how do
you talk to someone like that who's
corrupting the hearts minds and
murdering Souls I mean what are you for
the one message is for the youth and for
the parents and whatnot is you needn't
need to teach your kids the Deen you
need to be engrossed and in loving your
creator first and foremost beyond
anything else and knowing that you're
here for a short amount of time and if
you kill your heart and soul at the end
you're blind that you can't see these
things and then shakedowns gotcha and
what happens you're gonna end up in the
pits of the Hellfire and you're gonna
you know miss out it's gonna be
worthless what's the point you're just
like hypnotized there's that guy I'm
sure it's been listen to this not only
them the people who follow them who have
some money who have tasted some of these
things I'm not saying about young people
for whom all of these themes shining and
interesting but I'm saying to them and
people around them I'm sure hundred
percent when they wake up in the morning
after all this immorality and everything
they know how miserable they are these
guys are 10 or that or the other guys
I'm sure in the morning after when they
have all these like thoughts
suicidal thoughts with their most
miserable that's why they take more
drugs more alcohol and more money just
to run away but yeah but may Allah
garden to in these moments to think
about this and to turn their life
because we love them I'm miserable we
don't even have to yes we know this
there's no peace there in the heart
there's no pee just like Elvis Presley
you know he ended up where was I believe
he ended up you know on drugs in the
toilet you know these people you end up
living a miserable life you taking
people to the to the darkest places and
I'm surprised like when you have all
these like feminist groups you have
people who are advocating women's rights
these are the oppressors of women I mean
these guys are degrading women to like
the lowest level and women are like
singing their songs dancing to their
songs you know idolizing them but
they're actually molesting and with
their lyrics enticing man to be more you
know disrespectful aggressive with women
degrading women in the worst ways I mean
some people don't even listen to what
they're saying they're just repeating
things and moving to the to the to the
tunes but at the end just as you were
going over some of these lyrics and it's
just like it's the worst of things
imagine just put the music to the side
if they were just saying the lyrics you
could be running from them you'd be
running but now because like you're
saying they got to digital you know
these instruments and they're like
modifying things the voices and that's
like it's like a drug what were you
saying about that is like these are
these two that the digital way now that
it's enhanced and how how it's literally
brought them to do songs most of the
time you cannot even decipher what
they're saying because that's how
you just hear maybe few or the words of
the rhyme but most of the lyrics didn't
even understand the commercial and I'm
sure this is how it is for most of the
people today said me better they just
follow the crowd so they become famous
they spread and then everybody just
start listening and I guess in gets
involved in this thing gets definitely
shaytanic forth you can see these are
dark satanic forces I mean any Christian
any God conscious person especially
[Music]
sociology 7/7 or some people who will
show no a really nice funny can like
that how do you live and what lifestyle
day they showed was really not had
nothing to do with Islam yeah but - and
people people know like all of us heard
many of their songs they were not they
were never openly nothing like we see
today this completely and we knew that
was bad so when you as much as you say
this is harm you would be attacked or
why we cannot just have fun but now this
perfect example okay this is where at
least now we see what the next step so
my G
what's the kids tell us now okay but
this is just we're having fun but in the
song he's calling young girls to go have
sex with him not to go home with their
parents like directly saying this in his
legs
yeah and now kids you think you just
having fun with all the other kids now
what should I just say but do anything
but you have like for instance DJ
Khaled's and these guys who appraised
allah
they'll praise the Creator and all that
and then people like or you have these
entertainers out there some youtube
stars who will mix islam and they'll get
islam and they'll put it into grete's
somehow and they're people naive parents
others that be like well he's Muslim it
can't be that bad
no but we forget that Shaitaan is the
top and strategy and experience and you
know some of these are like the sheep in
wolf's clothing
and now you let them into the flock
we're surrounded by distance from music
from entertainment from banking what we
heard it's all the same now mixing is
fun good fortune you cannot say I miss
mixing falsehood with Islam because
false frontier is the main thing and
then just bringing is pharmacist and
trying to paint and to make it palatable
friendly friendly huh yeah this is just
foster this y'all so any Muslim who want
to follow his desires you can find many
excuses to say ok this is this is a toe
he's Muslim so that's it I don't have to
go deeper in research now but who
follows the Quran and Sunnah and try to
this is great this is really easy to
decipher because honest pathos in Quran
that the plots are really weak
ok very good
but for humans but we have the guidance
from Allah so with the guidance of Allah
this is not from us this is from Allah
that's why for us Shaitaan is strong
when we go head-to-head but we have the
message from Allah which is much
stronger and then the plot of Shaitaan
becomes weak so I mean again for any of
these people the DJ Khaled's the the
these guys these two what are they again
I heard
some some kinds some kids also in the
u.s. they're very famous social one of
them almost something yes at any time
these Kadeem this French Montana any
time they want to get serious in life
and they want to turn back to the one
who gave them life he's them he can
accept their their Toba come back around
and start living life not wasting this
precious second that you have every day
to do something wholesome and good
you're calling people to every
immorality that's out there you know and
we don't have to list all of them just
every immorality that look the lawgiver
gave the crater that happens in earth
you're calling people to break it so you
setting these trends these evil trends
you imagine what kind of level in the
depths of Gehenna
person will be but imagine now giving
the hope that if you turn your way
toward back towards allah towards your
crater you started being morally upright
and you start inviting people to
goodness to the purpose of life man you
have a tremendous work because you got a
huge following now and shove inshallah
this is another famous singer look at
his end how did he die in a car accident
and the driver was actually drunk so was
he drinking I don't know but look if
he's following the Deen Islam look that
would have you and end up in inshallah
protecting yourself from any of these
evils that fall just from just one
example of alcohol for instance we can
oh so and imagine all the STDs and I'm
talking about both the spiritually
transmitted diseases and the physically
transmitted STDs that are out there that
people are falling into these are the
heart killers the the afterlife
destroyers because they will destroy
your afterlife they will now bring you
any piece of contentment it's a drug
it's like taking a drug you're waking up
to this
you're going to sleep to it in the car
to it that's just intoxicating the mind
the heart body and so and now they're
trying to bring the Dean into it so we
had to I mean now we have to comment on
it to make you guys aware
don't fall for these tricks of Shaitaan
they're out there but when you know your
Dean when you're engrossed in it now you
can spot because the Creator tells us a
lot tells us to know your enemy so
you'll know his tricks and these tricks
they're always being put out there and
if you're weakened the Dean you don't
know your Dean you're not living it
you're gonna be stumbling from the next
trap to the next trap and all the way
into the depths of the Hellfire mellow
yeah so this is with love and concern
and Michelle law we can be connected to
our Creator to the Creator that heavens
and earth with all our heart mind body
and soul and remember that we have a
departure date this shove Michelle is
met it you know you don't know when it's
gonna come you don't want to be stuck
listening to French Montana bobbing your
head missing Salah or or dj khaled
there's even another guy like zombies I
was listening to and we'll cut out with
this a DJ Solomon or something had like
thousands of people in the street and
the professor sent me who lives on top
the video and had the whole streets like
one two in the morning this is their
downwash disturbing the people's sleep
and this DJ Solomon right it was a
Solomon DJ Solomon and this is and
people like zombies just you know moving
their head to the deep hypnotized
dude because there's no lyrics lifting
just music so just another satanic tool
on another satanic tool may Allah
protect our families our children and
help us again to stay connected to the
all loving Allah do the most merciful
man who wants us to be in Jenna we don't
want to
hurt ourselves by falling into these
shake panic traps and then we oppress
ourselves while also oppressing others
with all this fitna that's out there
thank you brother for sharing your
thoughts with me anything else you'd
like to from Bosnia Salam alaikum peace
be to you
have you guys heard this Baba quarterly
yeah you guys so if you listen to this
ya know yes sometimes but I don't
sometimes we know what kind what kind of
lyrics can you share with us what are
some of the lyrics that he uses first
word swear words yeah does he uplift a
woman or he puts her down with those
words she uses
you think go ahead what are you saying
you think he's sending a positive
message for women and for Humanity or
negative negative one he had agreed
especially because he's yeah he's in
jail
why is he do
all because of drugs okay so should we
give him a lot of activity should we
give him for trying to make the world a
better place
should we give him a thumbs up or thumbs
down let me see it
thumbs down beautiful all right so
hopefully we can substitute that for
something more positive you guys heard
of this group here it's called boo boo
Carelli yes yeah what does it call
Tolliver not to move okay tell me what
you guys think about this monkey stuff
do you know what kind of lyrics that
he's talking about what is he saying his
music glasses yeah like what's is good
or bad good you think it's good as big
he's talking he's degrading women
putting women down you know talking
about drugs sex all this other stuff you
Muslim right yes you think that's good
you think is no it's nothing yeah yeah
maybe not so good for my logo
yeah why by the studies of large numbers
over Oh you saying the things that are
that are bad they go for but what about
a law a law don't want us to go for
those things so we should probably stay
away from this stuff huh good stay away
so up or down which one down for booboo
Karev
bubu Carelli yeah what do you think
about these these guys I think they made
a name for themselves yeah him and Jala
yeah I think they're really good for the
mainstream audience but since I'm a DJ I
have to play that stuff so all you're a
DJ yeah I found the DJ over here yeah
you're Muslim right yeah what do you
think the kind of message is that
they're sending to the youth you know
the kind of lyrics I mean forget about
the beats now but just the words to
marry the degrading of women you know
alcohol drugs all these things that as a
Muslim you know we're trying to you know
live obsolete yeah but I think Muslims
in Bosnia that's like a big it's like a
wide range you know there's like they're
they're Muslims but they're not Muslims
and then there's the really strict
Muslims you know so it's like you never
know who you're gonna go up like here
for me like I identify as a Muslim since
my parents are from here my grandparents
my great-grandparents so I just
identified that but I don't really
practice it so it's like it's a
balancing thing yeah what do you think
about these messages with the grading of
women personally I don't like it but
since it's mainstream and the kids and
like 20 year olds 30 year olds listen to
it so I have to kind of play it you know
but for me personally I don't I don't
like the messages they're sending it's
grad messages yeah it is bad messages
but you know that's the kind of rap
music that's played so what about the
album cover it says
I made it he made a pact with the devil
what do you think about that
yeah I actually work though then when
they released my album the first worked
with the bubby yeah yeah yeah
one day first so you know the pushing
now personally but I know them you know
I work with them like five or six times
okay but that album was kind of a Miss
for them you know but for the album name
itself I think it's kind of stupid to be
honest yeah it doesn't make sense on
Bosnian if you actually try to translate
it it just um like I signed the contract
with the devil that's pretty much it
they signed a contract with the devil
yeah stupid yeah yeah thank you very
much yes
yeah what is he saying in his like you
like him too grading women and putting
women down and make it in like like if a
man came now and he started to grading a
woman would you tell him ago we like you
all you say stop just like these girls
as soon as they heard you criticizing
him they walked away
what because they're the victims they
said they recently had the tickets I
don't know for what what he did and the
kids in school they were collecting
money to pay for him like that's how
crazy it is Wow how deep it gets when
it's pretty much like you're bewitched
hypnotized by these satanic forces
subhanAllah
[Music]
so how do you transfer a service know
how do you feel obscene what else the
truth
ugly beseen Rouge no yes you think
that's good good
okay sure don't listen to brother
rhetorics yeah you think they're good
[Music]
not for young people okay thank you very
much just good it's nice it's nice to
find people who aren't so excited about
the poison that's being pushed out there
yeah Salima yes good good not DJ Salima
you guys listen to this sometimes what
are some of the words that he uses in
the songs is it good or bad it's bad so
you know it's bad yeah
you don't listen too much maybe it's
better not to listen at all huh
beautiful probably let's stick with that
okay yes yeah what kind of lyrics does
he use I'd be good or bad Oh me and you
me I will tell that yeah I do yeah so
it's a good message er or a bad message
you know he is from Boston so I support
him yeah are you Muslim why is that
matter
yeah because as Muslims we should
support good yeah I know I know I know
you need support but is that's the song
that's so if he's if he's you have a
good forces and bad forces so if he's
he's with the dark forces that are
supporting things that Allah don't love
then we're supporting the Satanic forces
yes I know I know for the Muslim but I
know I can't choose I can't choose yes
and you can choose if you want to listen
or you can choose yes sir is it is it
better to choose the good way or the bad
way how would go this over this better
that's what I'm talking about you Muslim
yes I must surround wali so let's choose
the good way because we here in body is
very popular what message do you have
for people who listen to him
well it's young people here like it's
new type of music everybody's listening
so you let your sister or your wife
tomorrow or any woman you cannot listen
to this stuff no it's poison huh yeah
you think it's poison yep okay good so
should we give it an up or down down now
for the book of marshal